is emotion and complex
the idea is the centrality of emotion in
the process
and the relationship of emotion to
jung's idea of the psychological
complex for sigmund freud
it was the drive theory that was central
to
um what moved things along jung was not
uh part of part of his break with freud
was that he was not invested in the idea
of a drive theory
so much as tracking emotions because he
saw the emotions
as being related to the numinous
qualities that came out
from the archetypes and very much
connected because the what what we call
numinous i'm not going to get the whole
history of the term or what it means but
it's a sort of a
uh experience of the sacred and
emotional
experience when we have these really
profound
uh experiences jung said that that's
sort of characteristic
of the experience of the encounter with
an archetype
so we saw emotions as being central and
related not to the drives
but to the complexes on one hand and to
the archetypes on the other
jung's original conception of the
complex was as a feeling
toned complex because it was shortened
to complex but originally
the term was a feeling toned complex
there's an israeli union analyst named
errol chalit
who wrote a wonderful book on complex
and he sort of
capsula encapsulated uh jung's ideas
in this way he says this is a quote from
shalit he says
complex denotes a network of
associations
images ideas memories or the like
clustered around a nuclear archetypal
core of meaning
and characterized and held together by a
common
emotional tone thus
still quoting shalit here thus the
complex embodies
three elements an archetypal core
around which personal experiences
cluster
and an emotional tone that serves as the
gravitational force that holds
this macrocosm together and uh
many people will talk about it as being
like an onion
on the outside is the surface symptoms
as we see in this
diagram on the right there's the
deeper down we get the associated as we
kind of work on the complex we get past
the surface symptoms
see them as symbolic of something
hopefully
and so by doing that we get to the
associated
experiences past experiences personal
experiences
and as we get more and more
working through it emerging from the
center
and highly numerously charged is the
archetypal core
and why would there be an archetypal
core because
when we have highly charged difficult
experiences
at any time in life it's a certainty
that other humans have had these
experiences before
and that is what's archetypal about them
in other words it's
they're common and it's often very
healing just to recognize that what we
think is a very personal maybe
shameful maybe a hurtful experience that
many many many humans
throughout history have had these
similar types of experiences
and when we get to that archetypal core
we begin to then have
access to this numinous energy access
to releasing emotion and getting a
better handle on
developing again when we when we're
connecting with the
archetypes we're beginning to
a differentiate the ego from the
unconscious we're less
uh possessed and sort of uh encased in
that
unconscious world but we're also uh
developing that dialogue and allowing
that energy
to flow so we have access to it to uh to
do our work to
serve our families and our communities
etc so
when we embark on the project of
individuation the first thing we
encounter on our inner journey as we
saw earlier are the objects found in the
unconscious the personal unconscious
young referred to these collectively as
the shadow
however in practice the elements the
sort of constituent uh parts of the
shadow that we encounter
are what jung called the complexes as
errol shelley
suggests we first discover memories and
images
of personal experiences after we usually
were
drawn uh our attention is drawn to them
because of some symptoms some
something that's interfering the
complexes
intervening in ways that we usually do
not want to intervene in our lives
so we explore into it as we tease it
apart we
find personal experiences clustered
around an archetypal core
and held together by a common emotional
tone hence
jung's term a feeling toned complex
so our initial dialogues and other
active imagination exercises would
likely
revolve in one way or another around
whatever our individual complexes are
and again
not only are we going to have a perhaps
an aptitude or a tendency
towards a certain kind of active
imagination in other words some people
are
some people movement some people um
writing things down
young obviously very intellectual loved
myth he had just written
symbols of transformation so he wrote
this very mythic
kind of book in the mythic kind of
scroll with his red book someone else
for me to do that might not be ideal for
someone else it might not be ideal
we want the our own typology and our own
personal experiences and ideally our own
complexes
to dictate to one degree another where
it's going to go because the dialogue
certainly at first
this dialogue with the unconscious is
going to have to go through
have to deal with complexes in one way
or another